mais tu te rends compte ton smartphone
il a été constitué à lise et en grande
bretagne
ils les pièces ont été fabriquées en
asie du sud est il a été assemblé en
chine par bateau et taïso pays bas et
maintenant qu'ils achètent pas très cher
mais la même chose chez nous tu perds
est jamais ce prix là ça tu t'en rends
pas qu aux couteaux franchement moi la
mondialisation c'est beaucoup de
délocalisation c'est de la concurrence
des travailleurs et c'est pas bien pour
notre économie
alors la mondialisation
[Musique]
dans cette vidéo je vous propose de voir
si la mondialisation a des côtés plutôt
positif ou des côtes est plutôt négatif
pour ou contre la mondialisation
le premier fait de la mondialisation
c'est le développement de certaines
économies qu'on a appelé des économies
émergentes d'abord corée du sud taïwan
singapour et puis maintenant brésil
chine inde ce qu'on peut nommer les
brics et bien d'autres pays encore et ça
la mondialisation a permis de sortir
beaucoup de populations de la grande
pauvreté les inégalités mondiales c'est
à dire entre les pays ont plutôt diminué
avec la mondialisation lorsqu'une
économie connaît une crise la
mondialisation par les liens qu'elle a
tissés entre les différentes économies
va permettre le maintien de ses liens et
donc en période de crise le commerce
continue pour nous consommateurs des
pays occidentaux la mondialisation est
plutôt synomyne synonyme de baisse des
prix par la mise en concurrence des
différentes économies nation au rang des
désavantages de la mondialisation il y a
tout d'abord la désindustrialisation de
nos pays développés
en effet les industries les entreprises
du secteur primaire et secondaire vont
plutôt se rendre dans les pays du sud
vont délocaliser
là où la main d'oeuvre est à moindre
coût ou législation sont différentes
la mondialisation par le fait qu'elle
met le commerce au dessus des états
qu'elle oblige les états à adopter un
certain modèle économique
mais ces pertes en quelque sorte un peu
de souveraineté et à ses méthodes ne
sont plus maîtres de faire ce qu'il va
chez eux puisqu'ils doivent respecter
les conditions du commerce international
à cause de la mondialisation certains
territoires qui ne sont pas reliés au
commerce international sont délaissés
sont abandonnées il est difficile pour
eux de se développer
ce sont des territoires qu'ils
deviennent vraiment aux marches du monde
auquel personne ne s'intéresse et que
tout le monde veut quitter la
mondialisation est assez négatif pour
cette église la différence entre les
très riches et les très pauvres augmente
avec la mondialisation les très riches
s'enrichissent toujours plus alors que
les pauvres n'arrive pas à sortir de la
spirale de la précarité la
mondialisation contribuer à dissiper les
inégalités sociales dans une même
population la mondialisation par le
modèle cas
on va empêcher toutes différences
régionales
il ya une sorte d'acculturation qui fait
que la culture propre à chacun disparaît
ou se dilue dans cette grande culture
globale c'est à relativiser car on
aurait certes il ya toujours des poches
de sous-culture çà et là voilà cette
vidéo est terminée j'espère qu'elle vous
a bien aidé à comprendre ce qu'était la
mondialisation et je vous propose
également de vous abonner vous avez les
commentaires pour poser vos éventuelles
questions vous retrouvez la synthèse de
cette explosé sur blu géo et sur la
société et je vous souhaite un bon
travail et après bientôt
[Musique]